صَدِيقٌ أَنَا لِلْإِنْسَانْ  *** وَدُودٌ أدعى الحِصَانْ
صَدِيقٌ هو لِلْإِنْسَانْ  *** وَدُودٌ يدعى الحِصَانْ
حِصَانٌ حِصَانٌ  ***  حِصَانٌ أنا حِصَانٌ
وَسِيمٌ وَأَنِيقٌ وَأَصِيلْ
وَأنَا ذُو الذَيْلٍ الطَوِيلْ
لِي صَوْتٌ يُدْعَى الصَّهِيلْ *** مَشْهُورٌ فِي كُلِّ مَكَانْ
.. لِه صَوْتٌ يُدْعَى الصَّهِيلْ *** مَشْهُورٌ فِي كُلِّ مَكَانْ
فأنا حصان
حِصَانٌ حِصَانٌ  ***  حِصَانٌ أنا حِصَانٌ
فِي جَرْيِي أَسْرَعُ عَدَّاءْ
أَجْرِي فِي كُلِّ الأَرْجَاءْ
آَكُلُ عُشْبًا أَشْرَبُ مَاءْ *** أَنَا أَيْضًا أَوْفَى حَيَوَانْ
يأكُلُ عُشْبًا يشْرَبُ مَاءْ *** هو أَيْضًا أَوْفَى حَيَوَانْ
فأنا حصان
حِصَانٌ حِصَانٌ  ***  حِصَانٌ أنا حِصَانٌ
أَتَمَرَّنُ دوما أَتَدَرَّبْ
فْي جِدٍّ لَا لَا أَتْعَبْ
أَقْفِزُ أَتَسَابَقُ أَلْعَبْ *** يَعْشَقُنِي جَمِيعُ الفُرْسَانْ
يَقْفِزُ يَتَسَابَقُ أَلْعَبْ *** يَعْشَقُه جَمِيعُ الفُرْسَانْ
فأنا حصان
حِصَانٌ حِصَانٌ  ***  حِصَانٌ أنا حِصَانٌ